hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com i've been working as a
professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong
and i've started to do some youtube
videos because guys i want to share with
you all my experience of pro trader i
want to show you guys how we actually
work
how we do analysis what are the market
dynamics
who is doing what you know what are the
professionals doing when the retailers
are doing something else for example
so if you want to know about all the
stuff that i know because i'm
working in this industry you are in the
right place today i want to make an
update on
tesla which is the big winner of 2020 so
let's see if it's still going to be the
winner in 2021
let's get into it
[Music]
so for those who watched my previous
videos so
on tesla i think i did it like three
weeks ago we were
around 8 10 something like this and i
was saying it's going to go to 1030. but
i was saying that you know i'm not sure
when and
i was saying that you have some support
levels uh
lower and that you need to be careful if
we break one
of those supports so first i don't need
the earnings
so the volume is much lower now because
the share is more expensive as well
okay so we don't care about it let me go
to the four hour time frame and let's
see what happened on the shorter time
frame guys
so i did my video and i was saying that
i'm very bullish on
this stuff so right now we are basically
at the same level we went to
900 it got rejected for some reason and
now we have this
nice uh channel so i did some updates on
my instagram so please follow me if you
want to
know about this uh updates that i do uh
there
and i said that we are now in this
channel after we broke
this and we actually i like to have a
lot of contacts on my trend lines and
when this
trendline got broken so actually then
there was a rally but then
we tested rejected we go lower now what
is happening
guys we are in this channel i knew we
were in this channel
after i had here one reaction so this is
the first one second one so then you
don't know
third fourth and here you know all right
after this
level you are able to draw this channel
and then
it acted here again and i'm pretty sure
it's going to act here we have one more
uh good news
at this level so i was basically saying
that i'm a buyer at
7 50 on my instagram last week and
this is because uh there was the 200
period moving average that was coming at
this
level and i also have the support level
of my channel
which actually has not been touched all
right that did didn't do it perfectly
you can arrange it
you know the way you want you know for
example if i do like this
then it starts all right you need to
connect here here
here and here as good as you can so
actually this one
fits better and once again you only need
four points to make
this channel actually three is enough
one two three
you can already draw the channel and
then see if it acts
well on the upside and then if it does
then probably it's gonna act
good on the downside as well so here
guys i'm a buyer once again if we break
this channel careful guys
uh it's maybe the time to stop your long
position but most likely we're gonna go
higher because
we haven't reached uh my level which is
1030
so let me go on a longer timeframe and
quickly show you guys
what i did here so i mixed illiot wave
principle
and fibonacci which is what i love to
use guys when i do
some technical analysis not on penny
stocks you know on those
bigger ones because they follow this
very well the penny stock is that crazy
you cannot use fibs the moves are just
too insane so idiot wave theory is for
those guys who want to know more about
that actually i finished the video but i
i want to change some of the stuff so
it's like a training on illiot wave
principle
so basically i read the book which is
amazing which is like
very hard guys to actually understand so
i sum up this book
so in the five patterns that you have
and i try so
to explain to you guys how actually you
can use idiot with principle to read the
market structure and here guys it's a
nice
five uh moves up it's a nice impulse and
it's not
finished all right so i'm not sure i'm
correct about discounting so this is
what is tricky with iliad
but to me everything fits very well once
again uh click on the link
in the description of the video and
you're gonna receive this free video
and almost done as i said so very
quickly one two three four five
and the fifth wave is not finished guys
then i use fibs and i measure
the preceding wave that was in the same
direction so here it's a
motive wave on the upside so this was
this one
i measure it all right and i apply the
move here all right
so depends on how you do now i have 1038
last time i had 1030
and then you checked the fib ratio one
point so let me get rid of the channel
1.618 guys this is the golden number and
most of the time it's reaching it when
you have this kind of one two three four
five usually the fifth wave is a ratio
that is
finishing with six one eight of the
preceding wave so it can be this one it
can also be the next one one thousand
four hundred seventy five then
we're gonna need to see what is
happening on the shorter time frame just
as we are doing right now
i very rarely see moves that are
finishing
here it can finish to do um to the 1.618
600 600 level would have made sense
because this is a golden number ratio
but between this one and this one no
it doesn't happen i mean very very
rarely i almost never
saw that so right now that we're here
i'm pretty convinced we are going there
i don't know how but we are going there
before breaching some major
support levels but once again this is
not exact science guys
so please be very careful and use
adaptive tools on the shorter time frame
to exit your position if it doesn't
smell good
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget
to click the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
do more updates on tesla
with stocks amc clvs or whatever and
stay close to shore i'll see you guys